Okay, so here we are in our editor, and we've got our form handling code,
and right now, it just prints, thanks, everytime.
Let's actually use our new verification functions.
So I've added a line here. I'm calling the valid_month function that we just wrote.
I'm sending in as the first argument to that function the 'month' parameter
that was included in our request.
So this will indicate whether our response was valid or not.
I'm going to go ahead and add this for the day and the year as well.
Okay, so we've got these 3 variables, and now let's actually check them.
If not (usermonth and userday and user_year),
we're going to rerender the form again.
If all 3 of these aren't true, we're going to render our form.
Else if they are all true, we're going to say, thanks,
which we have down here.
So to recap, we're getting our 3 parameters from the request.
We're running them through our valid_month, day, and year functions,
and if they are not all true, we rewrite the form,
and if they are all true, we say, "Thanks! That's a totally valid day!"
Alright, let's give this a shot in our browser.
Okay, so here we are on our browser. I'm going to type in a day again.
Okay, so I typed in what I think is a valid month, day, and year,
and when I hit submit, our browser says, "Thanks! That's a totally valid day!"
Let's go to the form again, and this time, we're going to type in something invalid.
Okay, now I've got an invalid month and normal day and year,
and when I click submit, the form just clears because we sent back the form again.
We can improve this a little bit, and let's start doing that now.